so we have H of X is equal to 5 X to the
1/4 power plus 7 and we want to find
what is H prime of 16 or what is the
derivative of this function when X is
equal to 16 and like always pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
on your own all right well let's just
take the derivative of both sides of
this so on the left hand side I'm going
to have H prime of X and on the right
hand side well the derivative of the
right hand side I can just take the
derivative of 5 X to the 1/4 and add
that to the derivative with respect to X
of 7 so the derivative of 5 X to the 1/4
power well I can just apply the power
rule here you might say wait wait
there's a fractional exponent and I
would just say well that's okay the
power rule is very powerful so we can
multiply the 1/4 times the coefficient
so you have 5 times 1/4 X to the 1/4
minus 1 power that's the derivative of 5
X to the 1/4 power and then we have plus
7 now what's the derivative of 7 with
respect to X well 7 doesn't change with
respect to X the derivative of a
constant we've seen this multiple times
is just 0 so it's just plus zero and now
we just have to simplify this so this is
going to be H prime of X is equal to is
equal to 5/4 X 2 though what's 1/4 minus
1 well that's negative 3/4 so it's 1/4
minus 4 fourths or negative 3/4 so 5/4
it's X to the negative three-fourths
plus 0 so we don't have to write that
and now let's see if we can evaluate
this when X is equal to 16 so H prime of
16 is 5/4 times 16 to the negative
three-fourths well that's the same thing
as 5/4 times 1 over 16 to the 3/4 which
is the same thing as 5/4 times 1 over
let's see I could view this as 16 to the
1/4 and then cubing that and so what is
this 16 to the 1/4 is
- and then you cube - 2 to the 3rd power
is 8 so that's 8 so you have 5/4 times
1/8 which is going to be equal to 5
times 1 is 5 and then 4 times 8 is 4
times 8 is 32 and we are done